foreign
how much money do we need in order to
remove a significant amount of carbon
dioxide out of our atmosphere
and what are the mechanisms that we
should use to spend all of that money
I'm the head of sustainability at
Shopify a company you may not know but
you might interact with every day
because our technology Powers millions
of online retailers
in 2019 we wanted to become a carbon
neutral company and be accountable for
all of our historical emissions
instead of buying typical traditional
carbon offsets that simply pay someone
else to not pollute as much as we
already had
we actually wanted to delete our
emissions
it quickly became obvious that carbon
removal those solutions that pull carbon
dioxide out of the atmosphere and store
it safely were very expensive and in
short supply
so to kick start this almost
non-existent Market we launched our
sustainability fund and committed to
spend a minimum of five million dollars
every year on the most promising
Solutions
now obviously we need deep emissions
reductions I'm not disputing that but
alongside this we also need to build the
world's capacity to pull 10 gigatons of
carbon dioxide out of the sky every year
by 2050.
now at the time 5 million was a big
number
and it was a really big number to spend
on something in its infancy and we
thought we were doing something
significant but then we totally hit a
wall
we weren't even thinking at the right
scale
we need to build massive facilities
capable of pulling 1 million tons of
carbon dioxide out of the air every year
and we need thousands of them and in
order to do that we need project
financing of about one billion dollars
per plant
now to put that into perspective our
five million dollar annual budget would
probably buy about 10 000 tons of carbon
removal every year
that's tiny that's only one percent of
the annual capacity of the size of the
facilities we need and like I said we
need thousands of them
so we've learned that in order to move
the dial on climate and to build the
necessary infrastructure we need more
money
way more money
and in order to do that we need
collaborations
and we need structures that leverage the
significant power of capital to create
even bigger effects
so now I'd like to tell you about what
we did next
it's a mechanism that we launched
alongside four other companies it's an
AMC
AMC stands for advanced Market
commitment and this one's designed to
help guarantee a future market for
carbon removal by trying to de-risk the
r d investment in capital expenditures
needed to scale carbon removal and grow
that industry
now why I think this is such a promising
approach is because it's not new
AMCs have been used in the past in the
health care sector to encourage and
accelerate the development of vaccines
it worked by essentially guaranteeing
the economic viability of production by
setting a price in advance this meant
that companies could justify the r d
resources needed to develop the vaccine
as well as the costs associated with
bringing it to Market
they just needed to know that someone
was going to buy their product at a set
price
so this AMC
borrows the idea of a purchase guarantee
to try to accelerate the development and
scaling of carbon removal
and to do that we set up a fund
and it's a pretty big fund it's nearly
one billion dollars
and it's called Frontier
but
Frontier has to overcome some
significant differences between vaccine
development and carbon removal
first vaccine development has been done
for a long time and we've largely worked
out the supply chain and infrastructure
challenges the operational issues and
the policy definitions but for carbon
removal this is essentially still a new
industry that faces all of these hurdles
for example a lot of carbon removal
Technologies rely on clean power to
operate because if they don't they'll
emit more carbon dioxide than they
capture but clean power does not exist
today at the scale and distribution we
need
second vaccines are developed by
established companies with deep r d
teams and experience whereas today
carbon removal largely exists on paper
in the lab or at the startup stage
there's only a handful of companies
worldwide right now that are any further
along
third the manufacturing facilities for
vaccines already exist at scale
but for carbon removal the largest
facility in operation today is climb
works as Orca plant in Iceland it has an
annual capacity of 4 000 tons which is
orders of magnitude less than what we
need
this means that today there's no company
or facility in operation that can
respond to the demand signal of Frontier
so to summarize for vaccine development
all these companies needed as an
incentive was a dollar sign they had
everything they needed to jump into
action and respond but today carbon
removal needs so much more
even though there's a lot of different
ways to approach this I do believe that
this is a significant Market signal that
Shopify alongside stripe alphabet meta
and mckinsey's sustainability have
committed to buying nearly one billion
dollars combined of the product
but the carbon removal ecosystem is
underdeveloped
even though Frontier is essentially
helping to underwrite all of the broad
investment needed to scale carbon
removal
this is an imperfect application of the
advanced Market commitment mechanism
because the carbon removal ecosystem is
underdeveloped
however
however this is exactly what we need to
do to supercharge progress by
accelerating Innovation it is so
important to take chances and to
experiment and as buyers of carbon
removal we have an opportunity to stand
up and do our part to build for the
future and this commitment does just
that
so now we have Frontier
which is the demand pull by providing
capital and resources through the
advanced Market commitment mechanism but
what about the other side of the
equation we also need a Supply push
to start in addition to all of the new
climate companies being launched we also
need companies from existing Industries
with transferable skills to jump in and
start developing carbon removal
I'm talking about
now don't get mad
I'm talking about Industries like oil
and gas
mining manufacturing infrastructure and
electricity who all have deep experience
building huge projects that's the
massive scale that we need that I was
talking about at the beginning
alongside this we also need to build a
robust management system to ensure that
all of these new carbon removal
Solutions are in fact capturing more
carbon dioxide than they emit
this is kind of along the lines of the
quality assurance quality control and
process trials we rely on to ensure that
our vaccines are safe and that they work
but most importantly we need more
practice doing the actual thing rather
than trying to get it perfect on paper
if we don't try we can't learn and if we
don't learn we cannot iterate and
improve
this AMC is technology neutral Frontier
sends out the demand signal but we do
not specify which technology should be
used to meet it but what we do specify
is the quality standard we expect in
order to ensure that real permanent
carbon removal took place
at the agreed upon price
now this Arrangement we're hoping should
encourage experimentation and tight
iteration cycles that should quickly
separate the promising solutions from
all of the distractions now I'd like to
ground this in reality by providing
three solid examples
of companies who are already on their
way and some of them are actually doing
the thing
first we have climb Works operating in
Iceland they use direct air capture
machines to filter carbon dioxide out of
the air and capture it for storage
and they've now since Broken Ground on
their next skill facility which should
be able to pull 36 000 tons of CO2 out
of the air
next we have running tide whose sink
kelp deep into the open ocean to lock
away carbon dioxide that's been captured
through photosynthesis
they're currently working through their
first scale deployment and they're
building all of the measurement
quantification and monitoring systems at
the same time
and third we have heirloom who plan to
accelerate the natural capacity of
limestone to react with and capture
carbon dioxide and lock it away and now
they plan to do this by accelerating the
natural absorption rates of the Rock
from approximately a year to just days
they're set to break ground on their
first commercial scale facility in the
United States in 2023
now there are many other companies that
are starting to emerge that I could have
mentioned here
however from these three examples which
you can see is the diversity of
solutions and we're agnostic about that
all that matters is that they achieve
the results within the set parameters
now before I end
I must address
the question of our own operations so to
start Shopify is a carbon neutral
company and we've committed to
kickstarting the carbon removal Market
our business is all about helping
millions of entrepreneurs succeed and
today they're experiencing so many
challenges
we have an opportunity to help them
become carbon neutral and to leverage
carbon removal in order to Future proof
their businesses which in turn
safeguards ours
now not a lot of them have climate teams
but we have the opportunity to share our
experience and expertise with them
and so what we're trying to do is take
everything we've learned about reducing
and managing shopify's emissions and
from vetting and buying high quality
carbon removal and we're trying to take
those lessons and put them out on our
platform to make them available for all
of our merchants
not only will this help reduce emissions
but this will also help create the very
Market that all of these new carbon
removal companies who are building in
response to Frontiers demand signal will
rely on
this is a feedback loop that will spur
Innovation and drive the development of
carbon removal at the scale the world
needs thank you
[Applause]
[Music]